hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
the revised ice is O one four six four
four - one changes classification and
monitoring methods are you prepared I am
st. an elaborate and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is present
inside lab routes believing social
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning this webinar is sponsored by
Beckman culture pop culture life
sciences is dedicated to empowering
discovery and scientific breakthroughs
the company's global leadership and
world-class service and support deliver
sophisticated instrument systems
reagents and services to life sciences
researchers in academic and commercial
laboratories enabling new discoveries
and violins biology based research and
development a leader in centrifugation
and suicide honor dreams
Beckman culture has long been an
innovator in particle characterization
and laboratory automation and its
products are used at the forefront of
important areas of investigation
including genomics and proteomics
performance start there are some few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment the answers are all for welcome
you can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we're trying to
get to as many questions as we can and
we'll follow up with you if we don't
have time today do you want a better
look you can enlarge the fly window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you can't see or hear this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or views
of TV night buttons will make sure to
resolve any issues this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the TV
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process and retain your credit now let's
get right to today's features we're
proud to participants welcome
Joe Jackson Joe has been involved with
particle counting industry since 1984 he
first joined that one as an electronic
design engineer and has since been
involved in both airborne and liquid
particle counter design as well as multi
sensor systems for facility monitoring
systems Joe has been involved in various
standards involving particle counting in
air and liquid he was one of the two
Americans on the ISO two one four six
four four - one revision committee and
how did the subcommittee to redraft
diocese is over 146 before - - standard
on monitoring a clean room currently Joe
is the life science application manager
at Beckman cultural life sciences
particle accounting and characterization
division so when I'll try to go for
teach it over for his presentation thank
you soon hello everyone and thank you
for joining us today the topic today is
on the classification methods so we'll
dive into that and where some of the
changes recently may affect what you do
are in the daily efforts for monitoring
clean rooms whether it's strictly
pharmaceutical biotech kind of thing
with looking at the what you would call
normally EAM or environmental monitoring
or something broader to do with clean
rooms in general so try and look at the
various types of application but mainly
focus towards the pharmaceutical and
biopharmaceutical world because that
gets to be a little bit more interesting
and tricky at times so just as a little
bit of background before the ISO 14 644
existed
most countries had their own type of
monitoring standard the in the u.s. it
was a federal standard 209 and a lot of
confusion and mixed efforts you know
affected people being able to consider
how the cleanroom should be organized
especially internationally so in 1999
the ISO 14 644 was created
with the first couple of sections or -
one and - two related to the level of
airborne particles in the air and being
able to look at the concentration in in
the air make sure it's appropriate for
various purposes it's important to
realize that this standard effects or is
used by all industries it's not just a
pharmaceutical or medical device or
biopharmaceutical standard it really
relates to anyone working in a clean
space and wanting to be able to
understand the level of concentration of
the particles in the air and again
knowing that it's appropriate for their
particular use that's clean enough there
are more than just the two sections for
this standard in fact today there's 15
of them we're going to focus on the
first two again basically looking at the
concentration of airborne particles
there are other ones especially some new
ones related to nanotechnology that may
be worth looking into should that be an
area of need but fundamentally one and
two are focus and relate to airborne
concentration one of the things is very
important to understand and I hope
everyone leaves today this webinar with
this clearer understanding even though
we have instruments particle counters
that are used throughout the
applications here there's really two
fundamentally different philosophical
you could say uses for it and one of
those is what we're talking about really
today focused on that is classification
and the other is a monitoring
application that is something where
you're testing more frequently often on
a daily or even continuous basis and
these are really two quite different
applications but often using exactly the
same instrument so hopefully as we go
through this discussion today that will
become clear and the appropriate use of
the standard for classification versus
other uses of different documents and
procedures for monitoring will become a
bit more distinct and clear
so just as a general discussion when we
look at these two types of uses that is
looking at classification and looking at
monitoring the frequency is the first
thing that is significant basically
classification is a formal study of an
area done maybe every six months or
every 12 months there are formulas for
setting up the number of positions in
the sample volume there is a singular
pass/fail criteria you either meet the
class or don't there's a fairly
standardized format for making the
report and it's somewhat assumed that
the area's room is fairly uniform of
homogeneous in terms of the distribution
of particles in the air whereas when you
look at the monitoring side you're
really dealing with something that is
done more frequently and you're trying
to know to understand the current health
you might say of the areas it's still
appropriate for the use and in that way
there's there's no formula for that it's
mainly a matter of looking at the data
that is needed to understand that level
of concentration of particles same with
the sample volume it's really defined by
the need for information a sense of risk
perhaps and there are often controls set
up that are based on commonly called
lurch and action levels there's a couple
of levels and they're often either much
lower than the classification used for
the room or in some cases higher even
than that so they're unique and not
necessarily related to the class limit
value that's set up in classification
and generally the report form takes
something like a quick graph or their
summary so it's a matter of
understanding quickly what that
particular area is at for concentration
and again that it meets the current need
one of the key differences with
monitoring is that each sample position
has some unique characteristics and it
doesn't necessarily relate to the rest
of the zone you could have one
it's extremely clean maybe even located
in front of a filter or underneath the
filter area where you may have another
one where operations occur or people
pass by even though it's in the same
considered zone or room you know we'll
have a different characteristic or
signature of counts of particles in the
air and so everything is unique when you
start looking at monitoring in terms of
the position whereas for classification
we're really thinking about the whole
zone area room biological safety cabinet
bench whatever that zone or area might
be so keep these in mind when you talk
about the differences we focus it as I
said on classification but we'll also
touch on the needs for monitoring is to
go through this discussion today so
classification monitoring two distinct
approaches to looking at concentrations
in the air so again when we look at
classification the room and zone as well
see as a closer look at the standard
monitoring each sample position becomes
the focus of the assessment
so let's look particularly at the
classification function for airborne
counts what is a standard that we've
addressing here this ISO 14 644 its main
purpose is two things first thing you
could say is defining the cleanroom
class being able to have a common
language I can speak to someone about an
ISO class five room and they'll have a
sense of what that means maybe it'll
bring up a mental image of someone
dressed up in a complete garment a full
bunny suit as we would say with even
goggles on whereas you might say in ISO
8 maybe it's much more relaxed just
labcoat iso 200 k something maybe even
fully gal not only just fully gown but
in a somewhat of a in court fully
enclose spacesuit type so it helps again
with the
understanding especially across
industries or internationally for the
level of cleanliness it's intended for a
zone or area it also helps put forward a
statistical sampling method for that
room and it's often something people
forget or don't realize at first when
you're doing the classification effort
we don't have 100% confidence of how
that zone is we haven't been able to
extract 100% of the air it even in a
good moment to know precisely what the
concentration is in that whole zone so
instead we use a statistical sampling
method basically choosing points within
the area and a certain amount of sample
volume each of those points using that
data set to extrapolate our confidence
that the whole area looks similar to
that data set or not and so really it's
defining a statistical sampling method
looking at number of points so it sets
up a minimum number of points and how
much air needs to be sampled at each
point to give us a high level of
confidence that that data set is going
to represent the whole entire area or
room so currently this is a chart you
would find well I should say currently
in the 1999 version which was current up
until December and this table basically
defines the ISO classes one through nine
and the six different sizes that you can
use a standard for to define those rooms
you don't have to use all sizes for a
particular zone just the ones of
interest for the life science industry
for example an ISO five mainly is 0.5
micron and 5 micron whereas for some
other operations maybe for working with
space vehicles maybe you might be
interested at ISO 5 but at point three
or even point one microns so it's really
dependent upon the application is hand
how to employ the chart for your
particular operation but defines the
upper limit in terms of the
concentration of particles per cubic
meter this is a
some concentration so for example it's a
tie so five at point five micron the
maximum concentration at Point 5 micron
must be no greater than 3520 H position
or you cannot consider it an ISO 5
classroom so that's basically defining a
pass/fail for a given size and iso class
these classes are very similar to those
that people may have experienced before
from the federal standard US federal
standard class one hundred ten thousand
one hundred thousand we're all based on
counts per cubic foot
so it was a different measurement
criteria counts per cubic foot versus
counts per cubic meter they're thirty
five point three one cubic feet per
cubic meter so this one hundred times
thirty five point three one basically
accounts at point five micron to the
same number similar for ten thousand one
hundred thousand so the values did not
change extremely for these particular
zones and there is somewhat of a
connection between the old federal
standard and the current fourteen 6:44
just in terms of cubic feet and a
federal standard cubic meters when we
talk about the iso it is important to
recall to from the standard there is no
need to actually sample a cubic meter
according to iso there may be other
reasons to do that for other types of
classifications but in i so it's a
matter of resolving the counts to two
you've taken to the equivalent counts
per cubic meter it's not demanding that
a full cubic meter be taken so this
standard which has been in place since
1999 almost it's more than fifteen years
being used in the industry quite
effectively to help people understand
the capability of an area room that it's
appropriate to the use finally went
through the revision process and
effective date December where this
revision was set so this is now
officially revised so we call it ISO 14
644 - 1 :
2015 so what what's changing well it
didn't radically change and it was part
of the effort of the group to make it
somewhat consistent with the historical
values and so the people's
classifications would not be altered
significantly if at all by any of the
changes made so we tried to be quite
consistent but try to provide a better
statistical base for the assessment so
in doing that a few things will point to
as we we look at this and I'll just talk
about really two of the major ones the
ones that really might have an effect on
how you perform classifications so in
terms of things that they're changing in
particular there was a need to calculate
an upper confidence limit value in the
previous document for sample areas where
you took a small number of space
locations less than 10 you had to do one
further step that requirement has been
withdrawn in the new revision the
frequencies of retesting used to be
specified by class if it was ISO class
fiber cleaner this period was six months
and if it was six seven eight nine it
could be one year that's no longer
delineated by class and the calibration
method and the number of locations those
things all changed
what didn't change classes are still
basically labeled the same way ISO class
one through nine that values in most
most cases are all identical we use the
same equation for the calculation the
sample volume and there's still a
minimum sample time of one minute those
things all stayed the same so these are
the four kind of significant things but
two of these that is a calibration of
equipment and
number of locations are perhaps a more
significant meaningful ones so we'll
focus on those again the new chart here
based on 14 644 - 1 2015 looks almost
identical other than the outlying values
here have been in most cases removed for
reasons of statistical accuracy so if we
look again at these two things we'll
focus on that the calibration equipment
minimum number of locations so the first
major change and I think the ones most
significant to people minimum number of
locations we've increased those in most
cases so that the Cystic oval idit e of
the sample set is improved we're trying
to find something that gives 95 percent
confidence that the data set you've
taken can be extended to the whole room
so previously this was determined by
taking the square root of the
measurement area based in square meters
it's now replaced with a lookup chart
and this defines the minimum sample
locations those can be increased you can
do beyond that especially if you have
certain high-risk areas you wish to have
good confidence about so in most cases
that means a small increase in the
number of sample points so let's look at
that chart so this is located in the
appendix some reason I'm not seeing the
chart display
one moment please okay so all right so
if we look at the chart the important
thing we notice here is for example in
the sizing the numbers for most sizes
will have increased for example if we
took 36 square feet
extremely square meters as an area that
we're interested in defining number of
minimum number sample locations in the
previous method we would have said ah
take the square root of that area and
square meters and that will be defined a
minimum number well square root of 36
would be 6
however the chart today says the number
needs to be 9 and again this is based on
the effort to try to make a stronger
statistical platform to make our
decision that yes room meets that
criteria with reasonable confidence with
95% confidence of that so you'll find in
most cases similar modest increases in
the number of points spread throughout
the area the second thing that's
important is a change to the calibration
method there always was a specification
that said the unit the instrument used
to execute the classification needed to
have a current calibration but how that
calibration was performed was not
necessarily defined in the revision a
specific method the ISO 21 501 - 4 was
specified and this has certain positive
effects first off than the previous
methods for different typical things
were checked in the ISO 21 501 - 4 we
really look at more than just those and
importantly we look at counting
efficiency of the particular instrument
involved this gains us a more consistent
health check you could say of the
instrument throughout its lifetime and
also more consistency between
instruments
so in the today's method of a21 501 - or
we really improve the overall use of the
instrument and make that mandatory so we
know we have a good solid tool to
execute the calibration so we get some
consistency remove and ambiguity between
someone doing calibration with method a
and someone else doing it with method
being we're basically saying use the 21
501 this calibration standard by the way
is not new it's actually been there
since 2007 and so it's something that's
familiar generally to the industry and
what that gains us is much more
consistent performance throughout the
lifetime in the instrument and better
unit unit reproducibility so our overall
counting accuracy and based on that
counting efficiency test improves the
downside of course it takes a little bit
longer to do that calibration takes more
effort and generally we'll somewhat
increase the cost of that but it does
gain something for us in terms of the
consistency of the instrument and when
you're setting up as a standard that's
important you want to be reproducible no
matter which tool you use which
instrument you use and who does it so
that's the idea of course of the
standard it's reproducible no matter who
does it and if an appropriate instrument
is always used I want to mention one
other tool that's hidden if you want to
say inside of the standard and this was
actually there in the earlier standard
in the 1999 standard Newman in the
federal standard that often helps speed
up the test for some applications but
not all as we'll see this is called
sequential statistical sampling it's an
optional method it's often very useful
for clean areas and again because this
is a statistical method it's using
statistics to foreshorten the total time
taken and when you're in very very clean
areas ISO 5 and cleaner in most cases
then the sample times can start become
long
because again we want statistical
confidence that the values we've taken
fall within our categories and often
that takes a certain amount of time to
verify that however because we're
assuming the certain consistency of the
area over time the sample point we're at
it doesn't change significantly over
time at least the time of the sampling
we're making a physical assumption here
in this method that we can quickly by
rate figure out that we're going to pass
or going to fail based on a few minutes
of sampling so this can be employed it
was before known as an XF and the
previous standard and in the current one
it's annex D again very much the same
function and use has previously and what
it really speaks to as using the rate of
counting to predict the likelihood of
passing or failing classification so
again is trying to use the statistical
methodology to help us move forward more
quickly in this evaluation however it's
very important to realize that if you're
working with the European or the Picts
annex one you cannot use this method
even though it's very attractive in many
cases but if you have called something a
great a in particular but if you're
using that categorization of your area
it's great ABCD you need to be very
careful about employing this it cannot
be used for great Hey because in the
annex one is very clearly specifies you
have to take a cubic meter of air that's
Adam and in that in order to call
something a grade a if you don't take
the full cubic meter or larger then you
cannot call it a grade a so we'll just
be aware if you've used this term for
your area grade ABCD you need to be
mindful as to where whether or not you
can use sequential sampling at all but
just you'll be aware it's an alternate
method and sometimes very useful
so for example if we have a 5 micron I
need to sample 5 microns which only
takes quite a bit of time in order to
evaluate because there's so few events
what happens if you have a lower flow
count system operating at one cubic foot
per minute 28.3 cubic feet per period
liters per minute normally you'd have to
run at least 24 minutes to sample and
verify that to take the full amount of
air and have a statistical confidence
however if your observed counts within
first few minutes are very low for
example if you count only one event at 5
microns in the first roughly 6 minutes
you could stop you can you can declare
that it will pass based on sequential on
method so again this is based on the
assumption that the error is consistent
at that point during the time of
sampling and then as you sample more and
more more in time you'll still be
getting the same result and you can
predict ahead of time how it will be
that you'll pass or your fail well there
is a companion section we're talking
about aerosol particle concentrations to
the classification document 14 644 - who
talks about monitoring now it's not
specific on how to monitor and again
this is not industry specific it doesn't
relate to pharmaceutical doesn't relate
to aerospace doesn't relate to surgical
suites it's a space talking about spaces
where particles in the air and control
those are of interest in order to have
good results for some application so
when you're the 14 644 - one was revised
also simultaneously 14 644 - - underwent
a revision again effective as of
December 2015 so this is a focus on the
other side of part
go counting and this is focusing then on
the monitoring side of it what do we do
day by day week by week to look at an
area and understand it's still
appropriate for our use so the title of
this is monitoring to provide evidence
of cleanroom performance related to air
cleanliness by particle concentration a
long title but fundamentally the
important word here is monitoring and we
talked about a sampling throughout a
period of time between those formal
classification efforts which again might
occur every six months or once a year
what's happening in between that time
it's important to know when that's what
the monitoring function is and also in
this document describes some of the
concerns with the pressure and airflow
in a clean space because often those
have an impact in the prevention of
particles entering by pressure or air
flow in terms of the changes of air
they're refreshing the dilution you
might say if the particle concentration
due to the inflow of filtered air so
basically this revision emphasizes the
need to consider monitoring strategy now
for most people working in the life
sciences they often have already a
process and procedure set up for it so
this might seem a little bit redundant
see we have one of those we have a
written procedure and that's good and
that's true but that's not true in all
industries and all companies so this is
a reminder that yes it's great to have
this effort for our classification but
we need to be thinking in addition to
what we do for the classification in ISO
14 644 - one with the idea of monitoring
and in particular we look at the
continuing flow of data over time we
want to know with a certain amount of
confidence that this area continues to
be useful to us so that's the idea
behind that the whole - - and what it
discusses so the flow of data over time
so basically when we do monitoring and
the more monitoring that we do the more
substantial it is the better we can
understand that the area is within our
boundaries and in many cases now we talk
about risk analysis we want to know that
we can operate this area and carry out
whatever process or procedure we and we
intend and we have a sufficient enough
quality of performance and consistency
that the risk for product loss or
failure or contamination in some way or
another is minimized in many cases we
can look at that in a way to minimize
operation cost and product loss by
having effective control of the air
around our process this is a quick
overview of the document in terms of the
points we talk about executing creating
executing maintaining a monitoring plan
and we start often saying you know in
this discussions risk analysis so it
speaks to that speaks well if we're
spending the money and effort to have a
clean and controlled area we must have
some sense of it being a risk if we
don't do it in that area how critical is
that you know or make them trying to
make Astro drug or are we just trying to
maintain a certain level of quality of
air for some other purpose so it's it
demands that we set forward some kind of
a monitoring plan it can be quite simple
or more complex depending again on what
we see is the risk and the concerns with
it we look for that plan to be written
and reviewed and approved by the
corporate quality group in an
organization we talked a little bit
about looking at the data and about
periodic classification in that document
so we do point back to the idea of
needing classification at some frequency
so again what we look about is risk one
of the things we talk about too is it
certain regulatory agencies so we're
speaking perhaps in the pharmaceutical
world of the you know TGA the
FDA the EMA other organizations that
have demands for certain types of work
for example the manufacturer of sterile
medicine has a higher risk factor and
has much more concern to these agencies
and let's say NASA putting together a
space shuttle well that certainly has
its risk and its concerns but it's
different than what's needed in terms of
a particular industry and so these other
regulatory agencies may impose
supplementary policies or restrictions
and so we may need to think about how to
monitor relevant to satisfying those
regulatory agencies this is the
important reality of monitoring as
opposed to classification observed
values may fluctuate considerably due to
factors such as but not limited to the
number of personnel present rate of
airflow operation of instruments
machinery and activities in adjacent
spaces and this is really at the heart
of the distinction you might say between
classification and monitoring and that
we acknowledge that these spaces are
somewhat dynamic and it's certainly
different in a space that has three
people working versus five or ten in the
same identical space will see different
concentrations and signatures in the air
particle levels so we need to take those
into account we need to maybe restrict
the number of people control that within
the capabilities of the space and so
forth so that's a lot different mindset
a lot different kind of concern then
simply classifying the area initially be
it at rest or in operation and
understanding the activities and the
effects of that over periods of time
week by week month by one month so again
a different intent behind the functions
of monitoring also important to realize
that these need to be somewhat living
documents when you create a monitoring
the process think about changes either
in personnel number of personnel may be
needed for procedure four types of
equipment being added and so forth so
occasionally these documents should be
reviewed and in the pharmaceutical
industry
I know it's always difficult to change
documents you have a standard operating
procedures and they should not be
frequently changed but occasionally you
may need to review those you know every
year or two should be an opportunity to
look back and say have we had an
effective plan have we sampled too many
points which is often a concern people
sometimes get overly enthusiastic about
their sampling demands and so they put
in too many points and really think
about that because you're making extra
effort you're opening up questions about
the whole monitoring scheme if you're
sampling a large number of points in
areas that don't have really much use so
really think about that maybe you need
to add points because of new operations
or new concerns so every year to
consider reviewing the plans in
particular I might point out a couple of
the addendums the annexes to the - to
document one is an outline of things to
think about when you set together a
monitoring plan and the second is to
look at the levels you might want to set
forward for alert in action so those are
things are a little bit different for
particles than other things there's a
lot of fluctuation in different concerns
and the same is true for pressure
differential in many ways because those
are both measurements that can change
dramatically but yet not be of concern
you know for example the pressure
differential in a room can change when
somebody opens door and closed it again
and so forth at several seconds a period
of time the pressure differential looks
usually if we're thinking positive
pressure goes low and you lose the
pressure you've seen just a few seconds
before we get then it returns you don't
want an alarm set for that so even
though it ultimately violates a level if
it returns quickly it's not a concern so
can be true of particle counts when you
see observe someone doing an
intervention or some other activity
that's expected or planned then you
might see any an increase in counts for
a moment or two and then a reduction
again and that would be normal again
that kind of process signature needs to
be understood and needs to be you know
calculated for adjusted for in your
alarm strategy
so this discusses that need for thinking
about how you set warning levels and a
couple of examples of things to to look
at it or consider so if we look at
applying this new revision how would it
work let's say we had a manufacturing
facility with seven grade-a rooms each
around 36 square meters and we wanted to
go ahead and do a classification what
would we need to do well previously when
we looked at 36 square meters taking the
square root of that value was six as a
minimum number of locations whereas
today looking at the table the value is
nine so we have an increase in the
number of positions and we have to do
that for each of the seven rooms so now
we have nine times seven
rather than six times seven for our
number of points as a minimum so if we
look at that and we say well it takes
you know a certain amount of time to do
each one depending on the sample rate of
the machine well if we had honored liter
per minute machine it would take us
seven hours previously now it's going to
take about ten and a half hours total
for if we have a slower flow rate
machine then that's going to take us yet
even more so we have concerns of that in
terms of the increase in hours to
execute this again there's a purpose
behind it to improve the quality of the
data by having an increase in the number
of points and so we're really only the
purposes is giving us a better view of
the room but it does come at the demand
of more time spent because you have more
positions for a particular particular
flow rate involved
how can we review that well there's a
couple ways to approach that and
actually maybe consider being able to
minimize that impact first off of course
is orchestrating the flow in an
effective way and being able maybe to
incorporate that into the instrument so
it's a plan movement to make that more
efficient in the process of moving from
through the various nine points that are
there under the new system and maybe
figuring out a way to minimize the
reporting side of it you're still going
to have to go out and sample at each and
every point and the demand and of course
at the end is I have to create a report
and file information can we speed that
up and the answer could be yes so one of
the things is time consuming of course
always has been the idea of putting the
kind of information you guys are on
paper tape and creating some sort of
permanent file whether it's a PDF and or
typing it maybe into Excel and putting
it into Excel Excel spreadsheet or up
into a Lim's that takes time and
increases the risk of a transcription
error so one of the things that's
possible is to use the electronics of a
more sophisticated counter to help out
in the process many counters today have
the in essence a small computer built
into it almost so you could say it like
a laptop built onto a particle counter
so you're certainly taking the reading
the instruments recording as it might
have done previously but now there's a
lot more information available and a lot
more information processing available on
the instrument itself so it helps in the
whole movement of the information so
eliminate the paper print out
electronically create PDF in the machine
and maybe an Excel output that would
certainly speed up the overall process
and that's possible today with some of
the instruments that are on the market
extending that 130 400 for example
provides that kind of capability and the
ability to set up files and structures
that could flow directly in
to a Lim's system so if we look at this
example and we say well a lot of the
time we spend in working with this is a
taping scanning data entry could we
eliminate those yes with certain
electronics you can bring those tasks
down to zero you still are going to end
up spending time for sampling the points
can't minimize that aspect I would still
have to go out and get the data set once
you have the data set you don't have
spend as much time crunching it you
create a report and now you're down to a
relatively short time using newer format
newer electronics on the instrument to
help with the process so this type of a
operation may make it reasonable to
consider this type of equipment both for
classification and for monitoring
purposes well what about the GMTs what
if I'm doing an x1 how does this impact
me well it does have some impact it's
not so serious but it's important to
realize that these two documents the ISO
14 640 4-1 and the pics or EU GMP
document annex horn are not are not
affecting you could say one or another
now there is some interdependencies
we'll see but it really are two separate
documents so what was done with ISO only
indirectly has an impact on these two
documents but it something certainly to
be aware of and that's because annex 1
references the ISO 14-6 44 - 1 document
to determine the minimum number sample
points so there's the effect really in
other words it's not that the ISO
committee rewrote GMP annex 1 it's
simply that that document the annex one
document points back to ISO for certain
operations in particular their minimum
number of sample points so this is where
an industry-specific document annex 1 is
impacted somewhat my that
to a generic you could say in industry
neutral document so again minimum number
of sample locations have we spoken about
we've moved from square root to the
lookup chart so when we examine that we
say oh gee I'm great a I'm gonna have to
do an additional number of points
because this is pointing back to I so
one so you're not changing that document
you're not changing a lot of things
about NX one but because it does
reference that and says use that method
to select it will impact your process
for classifying a grade a b c d area but
again you know we touched earlier on the
idea of sequential sampling and this is
an area where annex one differs from the
iso annex one says you have to take a
actual physical cubic metre to classify
grade-a area regardless of anything else
you might consider and so if you're
going to call it grade-a you have to
take that physical cubic meter of air
age each and every sample point also it
references ISO and 14 640 4-1 and that
calls forward then you need to make sure
your instruments fit the ISO 21 501 -
for calibration a lot of older
instruments don't necessarily would not
necessarily be able to be calibrated to
that and if an instrument is not in good
repair
it might also fail this calibration
method so this is something that again
keeps an eye on the health and
performance of an instrument and a much
more effective and efficient way than
any generic calibration method that
might be used so in summary we see that
these ISO revisions are affect the
number of sample points and this again
came in as of December of
20:15 so this is in effect today and it
may change the operation in terms of
time and you have to deal with more data
to record and more data to analyze it's
not in enormous increase but it's still
it's something to be aware of but you
will get better data you'll have higher
confidence the room will perform as you
needed and there are instruments out
there that can help mitigate that impact
that can help for shorten the analysis
of the data or if you go from a one
cubic foot per minute machine to a fifty
or hundred liter per minute machine it
will actually help save time in the
classification process so again keep in
mind that even though we talk about
particle counting in general and just
think about air concentrations when we
speak to classification we're looking at
these documents the annex 1 document and
the 14 644 document and when we're
talking about monitoring we're really
looking at your decision how to monitor
it's your SOP you could say you're a
monitoring plan that defines that it's
not defined by ISO 14 644 - 1 or annex 1
when you do your daily weekly maybe in
continuous monitoring you're looking at
your needs the risk you see in operating
your particular facility or area so with
that I'll wrap up the discussion point
and we'll turn to the questions and
they're there again I want to thank you
for your attention and here's my email
address if you wish to contact and also
I'd like to call your attention to some
forthcoming events in the United States
and North America we have our life
science users group events coming up
these are educational seminars that are
held at no cost in various cities in the
US in in May those will be held in
Berkeley California or valine California
Bloomington Minnesota in Malvern
Pennsylvania and Research Triangle Park
in North Carolina that schedule could be
felt will be found on particle comm
posted in your future I don't believe
it's up there quite yet but you should
be able to go to particle comm and find
out information out if those are areas
where you can you're located or travel
to also there's some other educational
webinars are be coming up on lab routes
on the same platform so keep an eye open
for these we'll talk a bit more about
ISO 21 501 there was a discussion -
coming up about compounding pharmacies
and also previously recorded one for the
USPS 787 and looking at particular
matter in liquid and therapeutic protein
injections a discussion of that and
there'll be ongoing subject matter
available so keep it tuned to the
offerings of lab routes relative to
particles and that may be helpful in
your daily work so let's go over and
look at questions that have come up on
the discussion panel here there's an
excellent presentation general thank you
so much for bringing that information to
us before me it started with all of your
questions
here's a quick reminder about how to
reach us today questions can be sent via
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we have two
as many questions as you can you have a
group great some great ones coming in
right now
but while questions are coming in we
would like to conduct a fall afternoon
how likely are you to recommend this
webinar to a colleague we would really
appreciate your answer to this question
so while you the audience members are
answering the poll I'll ask the first
question which comes from mark who asked
under the new revision how many counts
how many locations and for how much time
would you sample a safety cabinet work
zones that had an internal volume of 0.6
meters cubed
okay the charity is set up for something
obviously larger than that and there's
many certainly small cabinets in areas
biological safety cabinets just very
small operating areas that fit under
that so you would go to the first entry
in that chart which was a maximum of two
meters squared and that's the one where
you would use it so you could
technically fulfill that with a single
point and a single sample and under the
new regulation you could classify with
that and that would be all that is
required under that under the new
regulations that's great
our next question comes from Dominique
slash our question concerning the new
ISO twenty-one 501 - for what about
concentration limit measuring engine
calibration generally concentration
limit and I think Dominic's probably
looking at the maximum level is
something that doesn't need to be tested
at each and every twenty one 500 501 -
for calibration in the field certainly
it's something that's evaluated in the
design in the manufacture of an
instrument and tested but generally it's
something that is will not be changing
in an instrument over time because it's
fundamentally based on the physical
space of the the detection area in the
sensor and that really will not change
radically if it might happen - there's
other aspects of the calibration method
we'll pick up some radical disturbance
of that area so generally in the field
that particular function is not tested
there our next question comes from
entrance it's a little bit long so feel
free to read along with regional or
there a special text passage in the EU
GMT annex one that tell us to measure
one meter cubed
cos a and then he writes forbidden to
take the sequential method I think it is
only driven by the ISO 14 6 44 class 48
formula amendment of 20 particles 5
micron in the formula 20 per class limit
x of thousands which is the minimum
volume measuring great right and it is
your point is well-taken and exactly as
I was trying to define earlier
sequential sampling is very useful in a
lot of instances however it is not
something you can use for grade a under
the annex one and that is because it is
specified in section I believe it's
section 5 I'm not a hundred percent sure
by I don't have it in front of me
I think it's section five it could be
six but somewhere between four and seven
is the discussion in there that a full
cubic meter needs to be taken for a
grade-a area it also works out when you
look at the formula nowadays since that
limit is at twenty the formula basically
also would indicate the need out of iso
to take a cubic meter if you had a
target of 20 but that's incidental so
it's really if you're going to call an
area grade a you have to abide by that
classification demand and that would
indicate you must take the cubic meter
or at least minimum cubic meter for
anything if you're going to there for
later call it a grading area right next
we have a question from one planning
since I was having just completed
classification validation of a number of
clean rooms using the old standard in
June 2015
well if a validation need to be repeated
using the new standard fourteen six 24-1
sure a good question I think what's one
that's on a lot of people's mind there's
no demand that you would repeat it event
you know immediately using the new
standard again we try to make modest
changes in it so that the classification
of rooms are
unlikely to change and and assuming the
room is kept in good order that's
probably quite true what it means though
is that the next time a classification
is done six months or a year from now
you would go ahead and use the new
standard and and use additional points
as required to execute a classification
and you would say yes I classified
according to 14 644 - 1 :
2015 as opposed to what it is now which
is : 1999 that's a date code there right
so it's a year reference so you just say
I now classified according to this and
it would simply mean a few additional
points and ideally and probably true it
will not change the classification of
that area or room but it just means you
have more confidence because more points
are taken it's always true more points
you take for statistical effort
the closer you approach full confidence
so again the intention here was to bring
the old standard up to the point where
we could say based on the data with 95%
confidence this data set indicates the
whole room is ISO class whatever it
might be X ok great thanks next we have
a comment songs and dreams which much
Junie have to do mankind is it for
certain ayats or classes or for some
activity um do you have to do monitoring
no you have to have a monitoring plan if
you're going to have kind of an ISO area
know as you say oh I have an ISO class 8
room and I'm doing some very low-risk
work in it
but I am calling it ISO class 8 and once
a year I bring a particle counter in or
have somebody come in and test it do I
have to keep monitoring throughout the
year no there's nothing that demands
that you do that it's a matter of wisdom
based on your sense of risk of the area
and how changeable you feel that area is
so ISIL doesn't demand that you monitor
it does demand that you have a plan in
place which could be saying I'm not
going to monitor and here's a reason why
and it could be simple as that but it
simply says you do need to put that in
in writing and it could be extremely
simple it could be saying I'm not going
to do it or I'm going to do it once a
month that's fine but there needs to be
something put forward and that's what
the ISO 14 644 - - is pointing to you
need to have some kind of stated plan
and follow it and that again could be
simple and it could even be a statement
we're not doing anything in-between
so there's not a so to speak gun to your
head to monitor there's nothing that
states a frequency it's really based on
how you want to use that place and how
risky you feel would be to not have any
understanding of that area throughout a
period in between classifications great
information next we have a comment from
dilip's which says great presentation
and can you explain that the conflict
between ISO guidance on frequency of
certification specifically he once knew
about the FDA guidance and annex one
that requires every six every six months
which industry considers to be the worst
case please let us know what you think
well your personal opinion is okay
another good question because there is a
lot of concern again between what's
asked for by regulatory agencies and
what ISO is pointing to and again
isis/isil is industry neutral it doesn't
think about what's happening in the
space it just says if you want a
statistical method for looking at the or
assessing the particles in a zone in the
air here is a method when you come to
certain agencies be at NASA be it
surgical sleep be it sterile drugs there
are agencies such as the FDA and EMA
that mandate certain types of operations
and they mandate something differently
for aseptic operation of a sterile
injectable versus appointments or creams
so they have different approaches
depending on what they see as risk ISIL
is not going to come forward and put a
specific time period on as they had
before because it's really significant
and
relevant for a regulatory agency to put
that forward and if the FDA and NIA may
want to say for a a septic area it
should be classification every six
months that's not without some logic
there should be of course a general
monitoring program in those high-risk
areas that watch for day-to-day
variations but it's not a bad thing
every once in a while to step back and
take a more formal look a more thorough
look at a complete space or environment
even areas that are not typically in a
day to day manner used where you're not
really having a risk factor for it it's
still good to look at the whole area on
an occasional basis what occasional
might mean is again back to the
regulatory agency to set and if they say
six months okay that may make sense some
other groups might say hey every 24
months is fine so again it looks it's
really a matter of understanding any
regulatory demands that are specific for
your application and six months in a
case where you're dealing with aseptic
manufacturing to me makes pretty good
sense you know but with the monitoring
program you would be looking really for
changes in very key and high critical
zones and again back is back to the
difference with monitoring and
classification because classification is
just a momentary snapshot it doesn't
look at that I a make characteristics of
the room impacts of changes in the
airflow due to changes a failure of a
ventilation system filter failures due
to various different causes even
including let's say earthquakes
upsetting the seals on the edges of
filters all those things happen and
classification may catch those but again
it's done in a very infrequent basis but
it is a momentary more thorough study
and therefore of use and it's up to that
particular regulatory or Control Agency
as ISO is set today to put
a time period sorry next we have a
question from Lyle who asks in
pharmaceutical cleanrooms would it be
required to reclassify our rooms
especially where the number of sample
locations required is now higher
generally the answer would be no and you
again only approach this next time a
classification effort was needed or
specified for that particular room
you shouldn't have to reclassify it
until you come up to the next date which
might be one year or so and again
ideally even adding the number of points
shouldn't change your classification
unless there's some unusual aspect to
the room or zone so I wouldn't expect
the classification to change and it just
again gives you a few more points and
statistically gives you a little firmer
ground to stand on when you make your
statement oh yes this is a nice oh five
room at 0.5 microns so that's the intent
again of adding the points is just to
improve the statistical foundation of
that statement right next we have a
question from you our class the number
of sampling points whether the number of
sampling points you remain same for
classification and monitoring or can it
vary oh definitely can vary and this is
a mistake I think a lot of people tend
to make and maybe even have inherited as
an operating procedure from someone else
they say oh we had these are many points
for classification and therefore we need
the same number for monitoring and
generally that's not at all necessary in
many cases and monitoring involves of
many you know the significant reduction
of points versus classification because
generally monitoring is looking at a
particular operation or operations in a
room and it might be a large room and
the operations might take place in only
one or two square meters out of the
whole room and that's what you want to
focus on for monitoring where is my
exposure where is my risk where do I
want to have some understanding of
what's happening in the room
so in many cases the number of points
used for classifying will be markedly
different from those used for monitoring
but that's really a process by process
sense and it's something that isn't
specified anywhere but certainly look at
the amount of time and the information
gained by your monitoring methods and in
many cases people find that they're over
monitoring you might say they're taking
a lot more points and they're not using
the information and that's kind of the
key to it if you recording information
just because historically everyone else
has done it that way but if you look at
the data and especially if you have data
that fluctuates and nobody's acting on
it in other words there's no actionable
method it's like oh don't worry about
that point it always goes high you know
at this time and it doesn't affect
anything you know stop taking data you
know look at that again as a part of it
an annual or maybe biannual review every
two years look at your methods and and
say does it still make sense to be
taking this point or even should we add
them but in most cases the number of
monitoring points will be a small set
subset of what you do for classification
okay and along the same line new up has
a column a question asking are these
requirements only for clean rooms or non
sterile manufacturing areas um for any
the ISIL socialists you know focus or be
specific about the ISO the ISO 14 644
speaks to any room where you want to
control the particle levels in the air
so sometimes people use clean room in a
few different ways it's a matter of you
know what what's been needed in terms of
clean room but if you're talking about
the air in the clean room and the
particles in the air a concentration of
it this can be used for that and it's
not a matter of being stirred or not
stir oh it's a matter really of do I
want to control the level of airborne
particles and this is a way to analyze
or understand
that you've got a base that you can use
for a particular application and the
application again is not something ISO
14 644 takes into account now annex one
very much takes that into account says
oh you're doing something where you're
not supposed to have asked your product
you do this okay and that's fine that's
what one industry asked for ISO again is
industry neutral and it's just a method
to use for evaluating a space where
you're wanting to understand the
concentration of airborne particles and
determine does that meet my needs so
again it's important to realize I chose
industry neutral it doesn't think about
the application you could be painting a
car you could be doing surgery it
doesn't think about that it just simply
says here's a way to do it and something
that will give you 95% confidence if
it's done correctly and that that's the
end of that subject and anything beyond
that whether you're doing stirol'
monster appointments anything else is a
province of a regulatory demand or GMP
and not for myself okay next we have a
question from Jeff glass the prior
version of is over 14 644 - - required
reclassification of ISO plus five to be
done every six months that table and
table - has been removed
that's still the expectation for
pharmaceuticals ISO five every six
months or would 12 months now he
followed based on the section 5 of
current version of ISO 14:6 44 - 2 well
without knowing anything further about
what's being done in the room you would
say oh I could go to 12 months on the
the question that has to be asked is you
know what's being done and has a
regulatory agency set forward a
particular constraint because you may
find that a regulatory agency says oh
every six months must be followed that's
a decision that you know is based on the
GMP not on ISIL ISIL is probably you
could say the
the larger said or the more adaptable
classification document but then you get
to specific needs such as annex one or
the FDA estro guidance and you find
particular direction for a particular
application so without knowing the
particular use immediately you could say
oh I fall back to what it is currently
and that is twelve months and I can
relax my classification however you may
also be under the mid of the of a
regulatory agency that says no that's
not quite sufficient for the risk
involved we want it done more frequently
so I so again is not looking at a
particular application whereas certainly
the regulatory agencies in their various
guidances and GMP put forward very
specific demands on users of cleanrooms
okay and as a follow-up Jeff alas is the
optional test for air flow visualization
so filter leakage recovery ephedra
listed in the older version of bio 14
644 - to annex a going to end up
anywhere so they does repeat in the new
versions of either ISO 14 6 44 - 1 or 2
okay
a good question and if you've been in
industry while it's probably something
that might pop on your mind it is going
to end up in the - 3 forthcoming - 3
version so it's being ported over to a
different 14 644 document so for the
meantime you could use what that current
heard it existed and might be in your
monitoring plan there will be some
future release of - 3 I believe probably
within the next year I'm not I'm not in
that committee and I don't know
precisely but I know it's definitely an
ongoing work and you should see some
definition there I don't think they're
going to radically change so you know I
don't expect any shift of that
recommended of further testing for air
flow and visualization but that will be
in - 3 for visualization that's
something that's very important for
regulatory agencies so if you fall under
province then dynamic visualization
especially of storoe fill areas is much
in the interest of FDA they've written
some 483 s really relate to people not
understanding how the room works under
dynamic conditions and in high-risk
operations so keep that in mind as a
separate topic but that's not ISO that's
not 14 644 again that's specific to GMP
and to a particular regulatory agency so
high-risk operations visualizations are
very important and not just static but
dynamic too and information there next
we have a question from Federico to ask
the practical limits are you showing on
the table are these non-viable particles
viable particles or both I suspect the
proper answer you could say is both it
isn't specific and it's basically
generally considered in that table to
reference from the pharmaceutical world
non-viable particles but truthfully I
think a better title is total and that
anything that's in the air be it living
or not living or be it viable that is
able to reproduce or not to the particle
counter and to the table is not
significant
there was a particle counter sees a
organism or skin flake with a bunch of
organisms on it as a particular solid
entity in the air it doesn't think of it
as viable or not and it says there's one
of those it counts it so the table is
really you could say non-viable
particles but it's also I think a better
phrase to have called it total and if
you notice in the document it doesn't
use either phrase in discussing that in
the ISO document it just says airborne
particulates okay next we have a
question from nominee concerns what
tests then have to be performed during
calibration okay and I'm going to guess
this is probably looking at 21 501 - 4
in particular and and again there's a
difference between what's done
production or initial design versus
what's done in the field because some
test doing them in the field are limited
but if it's a 21500 1-4 type test you're
looking for you know size definition
you're looking for verification of the
volume sampled either by a airflow test
plus time because you're always
reporting counts per volume so you need
to verify that and then you also want to
look at your counting efficiency at a
couple of different sizes as specified
and document those would all be things
that are critical to the diet or to
fulfilling a 21500 1-4 type a
calibration and you know that's
something that I could handle separately
with Dominique here and we will be
having it further more detailed
discussion of 21 501 on a lab routes of
seminar in next couple of months I don't
think there's an exact date but you know
that's the will be forthcoming in more
detailed topic okay great all we have
time for one more question and that
question is from Jeff who says if I
classify an ISO five grade a area with
ten locations and routinely monitor four
locations based on risk this expectation
that I reclassify every six months by
taking those ten ten locations or is the
frequent monitoring being done routinely
at four locations enough to offset that
and the reclassification
reclassification was not necessary okay
and this is where again that choice of
the designation of grade a creates a
different demand than just a simple ISO
five statement ISO five alone would
allow you to consider continuing
operation based on good data out of
those four positions but grade a would
not any grade a demands you go back and
you would classify on a more frequent
period and all points so you can't
shorten
period or you can use that data if
you're calling it great a and so this is
an important distinction and again a
focus on something that as ISO five
would be industry neutral and not
thinking about what you're doing
whereas once you say great a you're
pointing to a particular function that
is manufacturer or medicines that is
unique and has its own demands so
unfortunately if you are calling a gray
day you're going to fall into the demand
that you do all ten points on that more
frequent basis and you can't avoid that
or you have to change the designation
you can't call it gray day then well
that was fantastic
thank you again Joe for bringing us this
presentation to have any final comments
for us before you ankle um first off
thank you and thank thanks to everyone
there in lab roots too for conducting
all this putting it together thank you
everybody for for attending it is a
interesting and kind of confusing topic
and hopefully today we've made a little
progress especially in this distinction
between classification and monitoring
and and to define how each one can be
used even again as we say often using
the same instrument but these topics are
important and keeping control of an area
at an appropriate level is something
that that monitoring can help us with
and then the less frequent but more
formal study on a classification helps
everyone have the sense of confidence
that an area will perform in the way
that they needed to to execute their
work so again thanks everyone
certainly will be happy to take other
questions in we'll try to answer these
by email so again thank you for your
attention and appreciate your time today
yep that was that was terrific thank you
enjoy again for bringing this
presentation to us and special thanks to
Beckman culture for sponsoring this
event and for Ian I just wanted to let
you know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing
through August II 2016 you receive an
email from us alerting you when it's
available for on-demand and posted on
labyrinths calm feel free to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join us today thank you
again for logging in and participating
in today's broadcast event hope to see
you next time bye bye